Soy viajero de toda la vida.
Incluso de niño,
calculé que sería más barato
ir a un internado en Inglaterra
que a la mejor escuela cercana a la casa de mis padres en California.
Así, desde los 9 años,
volaba solo varias veces al año
sobre el Polo Norte, solo para ir a la escuela.
Y, claro, cuanto más volaba más me encantaba volar,
por eso ni bien terminé la secundaria,
conseguí un trabajo limpiando mesas
para poder pasar cada estación de mis 18 años
en un continente diferente.
Y luego, casi inevitablemente, me hice cronista de viajes
para aunar trabajo y relajo.
Y realmente empecé a sentir que si uno tiene la fortuna
de caminar a la luz de las velas por los templos de Tíbet
o vagar por el malecón de La Habana
rodeado de música,
podía llevar esos sonidos, los cielos de cobalto
y el destello del mar azul
de regreso a casa, a los amigos,
y aportar algo de magia
y claridad a la propia vida.
Salvo que, como ya saben,
una de las primeras cosas que uno aprende al viajar
es que ningún lugar es mágico a menos que uno lo vea con la mirada apropiada.
Uno lleva a un hombre irascible al Himalaya,
y se quejará de la comida.
Por eso creo que la mejor manera
de cultivar una mirada más atenta y apreciativa
fue, curiosamente,
ir a ninguna parte, y simplemente sentarse.
Claro, sentarnos es nuestra forma de conseguir
lo que más anhelamos y necesitamos en nuestras vidas aceleradas, un descanso.
Pero fue también la única forma
como pude tamizar mi repertorio de experiencias
y darle sentido al futuro y al pasado.
Y así, para mi gran sorpresa,
descubrí que ir a ninguna parte
era tan apasionante como ir al Tíbet o a Cuba.
Y cuando digo ir a ninguna parte, hablo de nada más intimidante
que tomarse unos minutos cada día,
o unos días cada estación,
o incluso, como hacen algunos,
unos años en la vida,
para estar quieto el tiempo suficiente
para averiguar qué nos motiva más,
para recordar qué nos hace realmente felices
y para recordar que, a veces,
ganarse la vida y honrar la existencia
van en direcciones opuestas.
Claro, esto es lo que los sabios a través de los siglos,
en todas las tradiciones, nos han dicho.
Es una idea antigua.
Hace más de 200 años, los estoicos nos recordaban
que no es la experiencia lo que hace nuestra vida,
sino lo que hacemos con ella.
Imagina que un huracán de repente arrasa con tu pueblo
y reduce todo a escombros.
Un hombre queda traumatizado de por vida.
Pero otro, quizá incluso su hermano, casi se siente liberado,
y decide que es una gran oportunidad de empezar su vida de nuevo.
Es exactamente el mismo acontecimiento
pero con respuestas radicalmente diferentes.
Nada es bueno o malo en sí, como nos dice Shakespeare en "Hamlet";
es el pensamiento el que lo vuelve así.
Esta ha sido sin duda mi experiencia como viajero.
Hace 24 años emprendí el viaje más alucinante
por Corea del Norte.
El viaje duró pocos días.
Pero sentado he vuelto allí mentalmente,
he tratado de comprenderlo, de encontrarle un sitio en mis pensamientos
y eso ha durado ya 24 años
y probablemente dure para siempre.
El viaje, en otras palabras, me dio algunas vistas increíbles
pero solo al sentarme tranquilo
puedo tornar esas vistas en visiones duraderas.
A veces pienso que gran parte de nuestra vida
ocurre dentro de la mente,
en recuerdos, imaginación, interpretación o especulación,
y que si realmente quiero cambiar mi vida
mejor podría empezar cambiando mi mente.
Pero nada de esto es nuevo;
por eso Shakespeare y los estoicos nos lo decían hace siglos,
pero Shakespeare nunca tuvo 200 emails por día.
(Risas)
Los estoicos, que yo sepa, no estaban en Facebook.
Todos sabemos que en nuestra vida a la carta
una de las cosas más demandadas
somos nosotros mismos.
Donde quiera que estemos, a cualquier hora, día o noche,
nuestros jefes, corresponsales o padres, pueden ubicarnos.
Los sociólogos han hallado que en años recientes
los estadounidenses trabajan hoy, menos horas que hace 50 años,
pero sienten que trabajan más.
Tenemos cada vez más dispositivos que ahorran tiempo,
pero con frecuencia parece que tenemos cada vez menos tiempo.
Podemos hacer contacto más fácilmente con personas
en los rincones más remotos del planeta,
pero a veces en ese proceso
perdemos el contacto con nosotros mismos.
Y una de mis sorpresas más grandes, como viajero,
ha sido descubrir que a menudo es exactamente
la gente que nos ha permitido llegar a cualquier sitio
la misma que quiere ir a ninguna parte.
En otras palabras, precisamente esas personas
que crearon las tecnologías
que sobrepasan muchos límites del pasado,
son las más sabias sobre la necesidad de tener límites,
aun si se trata de tecnología.
Una vez fui a las oficinas de Google
y vi todas las cosas que muchos han oído;
casas en los árboles bajo techo, mesas elásticas,
trabajadores con 20 % de su tiempo libre
para dejar volar la imaginación.
Pero lo que más me impresionó
fue que mientras esperaba mi ID digital,
un funcionario me contó del programa
que él estaba por empezar para enseñarle a otros empleados
aficionados al yoga, a volverse entrenadores.
Otro funcionario me contó del libro que estaba por escribir
sobre el motor de búsqueda interno,
y sobre las formas como la ciencia ha demostrado empíricamente
que estar quieto, o en meditación,
lleva no solo a mejoras en la salud o a clarificar el pensamiento,
sino a la inteligencia emocional.
Tengo otro amigo en Silicon Valley,
uno de los portavoces más elocuentes
de las últimas tecnologías,
quien fue uno de los fundadores de la revista Wired, Kevin Kelly.
Kevin escribió su último libro sobre nuevas tecnologías
sin un smartphone, laptop o TV en su casa.
Y, como muchos en Silicon Valley,
se empeña en respetar
lo que llaman el "sabbath de Internet",
en el que durante 24 o 48 horas cada semana
se desconectan por completo
para recuperar el sentido de orientación y mesura
que necesitarán cuando vuelvan a la vida en línea.
Una de las cosas que quizá la tecnología no siempre nos da,
es cómo usarla sabiamente.
Y hablando del sabbath,
miren los 10 mandamientos,
solo se usa el adjetivo "santo"
para el día de reposo.
Tomamos el libro sagrado de los judíos, la Torá;
el capítulo más largo es sobre el sabbath.
Todos sabemos que uno de los lujos más grandes,
es el espacio vacío.
En muchas piezas musicales, las pausas o silencios
les dan su belleza y su forma.
Y, como escritor,
a menudo trataré de incluir muchos espacios vacíos en la página
para que el lector pueda completar mis pensamientos y oraciones
y así dar rienda suelta a su imaginación.
En el terreno físico, claro, mucha gente,
si tiene los recursos,
trata de conseguir un lugar en el campo, un segundo hogar.
Nunca llegué a tener esos recursos,
pero a veces pienso que cuando quiera,
puedo tener un segundo hogar en el tiempo, si no puedo en el espacio,
con solo tomarme un día libre.
Y nunca es fácil porque, claro, si lo hago, paso gran parte del tiempo
preocupado por las cosas extra
que se me vendrán encima al día siguiente.
A veces pienso que es mejor sacrificar comida, sexo o vino,
que la oportunidad de leer mis correos.
(Risas)
Cada temporada trato de tomarme 3 días de descanso
pero una parte de mí se siente culpable de dejar a mi pobre esposa
o ignorar esos correos de mis jefes,
aparentemente urgentes,
o quizá perderme el cumpleaños de un amigo.
Pero tan pronto como llego a un lugar tranquilo de verdad,
me doy cuenta de que es solo yendo allí
que tendré algo novedoso, creativo o alegre para compartir
con mi esposa, mi jefe o mis amigos.
De lo contrario, realmente,
solo les comparto mi agotamiento o mis distracciones,
que no son ningunas bendiciones.
Por eso a los 29 años,
decidí rehacer toda mi vida
bajo la idea de ir a ninguna parte.
Una noche volvía de la oficina,
era pasada la medianoche, estaba en un taxi yendo hacia Times Square,
y de repente me di cuenta de que corría tanto
que no podía ponerme al día con mi propia vida.
Mi vida entonces, en realidad,
era más o menos lo que había soñado de niño.
Tenía amigos y colegas muy interesantes,
tenía un bonito apartamento en Park Avenue y la calle 20,
mi trabajo me parecía fascinante, escribiendo sobre asuntos mundiales.
Pero no podía aislarme de todo eso
para oír mi voz interior,
para apreciar si en realidad era verdaderamente feliz.
Así que abandoné mi vida soñada
y me fui a una habitación simple en una de las callejuelas de Kioto, Japón,
el lugar que había ejercido durante mucho tiempo una atracción
gravitacional muy fuerte y misteriosa sobre mí.
Incluso de niño
miraba una pintura de Kioto y sentía que la reconocía;
la había visto antes de posar mis ojos sobre ella.
Es también, como saben,
una ciudad hermosa rodeada de colinas,
con más de 2000 templos y santuarios,
donde mucha gente ha meditado durante 800 años o más.
A poco de mudarme allí, terminé donde hoy estoy
con mi mujer, anteriormente con nuestros hijos,
en un apartamento de 2 habitaciones en medio de la nada
donde no tenemos bicicleta, ni auto,
ni TV que se pueda entender.
Aun así tengo que sostener a mis seres queridos
como cronista de viajes y periodista.
Claramente no es lo ideal para avanzar en el trabajo
o para la conmoción cultural
o la diversión social.
Pero me di cuenta de que me da lo que más aprecio
que son los días
y las horas.
Nunca he tenido que usar un móvil allí.
Casi nunca tengo que mirar la hora,
y cada mañana al despertar,
realmente el día se despliega delante de mí
como una amplia pradera.
Y cuando la vida vomita una de sus sorpresas desagradables,
como sucederá, más de una vez;
cuando un médico entre en mi habitación
con una expresión seria,
o cuando un coche vire repentinamente delante de mí en la autopista,
sé, desde lo más profundo,
que el tiempo que pasé en ningún lugar
me dará más sustento
que el que he pasado corriendo por Bután o la Isla de Pascua.
Siempre seré un viajero,
mi medio de vida depende de eso.
Pero una de las bellezas de viajar
es que permite llevar la calma
a la agitación y la conmoción del mundo.
Una vez subí a un avión en Frankfurt, Alemania.
Una joven alemana se sentó a mi lado
y conversamos muy amigablemente
durante unos 30 minutos.
Luego se dio vuelta
y quedó inmóvil durante 12 horas.
Ni una vez encendió el monitor de video,
nunca sacó un libro, ni siquiera durmió;
se quedó inmóvil.
Me transmitió algo de su claridad y su calma.
Noto que hoy en día, cada vez más personas toman medidas conscientes
para generar espacios en sus vidas.
Algunas personas van a resorts "agujero negro"
en los que pagan cientos de dólares la noche
por entregar el móvil y la laptop
en la recepción a la llegada.
Conozco algunos que antes de ir a dormir,
en vez de repasar los correos,
o mirar YouTube,
simplemente apagan las luces, escuchan algo de música,
notan que duermen mucho mejor
y se despiertan mucho más alertas.
Una vez tuve la suerte
de conducir por las elevadas montañas oscuras detrás de Los Ángeles,
donde el gran poeta, cantante
y galán internacional, Leonard Cohen,
vivió y trabajó muchos años como monje a tiempo completo
en el Centro Zen Mount Baldy.
Y no me sorprendió del todo
cuando el disco que lanzó a los 77 años,
al que tituló deliberadamente con el poco sexy, "Viejas ideas",
fue número uno en las listas de 17 países,
y quedó entre los 5 primeros en otros 9 países.
Algo dentro nuestro, creo, pide a gritos
el sentido de intimidad y profundidad que nos dan personas como esas
que asumen el tiempo y los problemas de meditar.
Creo que muchos tenemos la sensación, yo desde luego la tengo,
de estar parados a 5 cm de una pantalla enorme,
con mucho ruido, atestada de gente,
que cambia segundo a segundo,
y esa pantalla es nuestra propia vida.
Solo apartándonos un poco, y yendo un poco más atrás,
permaneciendo quietos,
podemos empezar a ver el sentido del lienzo
y a captar la imagen mayor.
Unas pocas personas hacen eso por nosotros, yendo a ninguna parte.
Por eso, en la era de la aceleración,
nada puede ser más estimulante que ir lento.
En la era de la distracción,
nada es más lujoso que prestar atención.
En la era del constante movimiento,
nada es tan urgente como quedarse inmóvil.
A donde vayan las próximas vacaciones
a París, Hawái, o Nueva Orleáns;
apuesto a que la pasarán de maravilla.
Pero si quieren volver a casa vivos y llenos de esperanza,
enamorados del mundo,
creo que podrían probar ir a ningún sitio.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)